un commandant au turn tout le monde sait
ce que je pense des débutants exactement
ce que je pense des auto pilot en quoi
puis-je vous aider qu'est-ce que je peux
faire pour vous messieurs seniors rien
ils ne font que compliquer les choses je
préfère de loin faire le travail moi
même c'est pour ça que j'ai invité le
débutant
bonjour non baisse le protocole nous
impose de le former sur le terrain va
nous faire les yeux de cocker et j'ai
toujours eu horreur de ce regard de
vitesse regarder le nom regarde le nom
l'éclair nom alexis le regard de l'autre
en garde non non non non on regarde le
débutant à
très bien d'accord tu as gagné
écoute faisait frais g strings fils de
monsieur écoute petit primo tu prends la
parole que si on clad entendu tu te tais
secundo respecte la combinaison cette
combinaison est pleine de symboles elle
ne protège pas que ta petite personne
elle protège l'univers tout entier c'est
une promesse au monde c'est l'engagement
total et personnel de tout mettre en
oeuvre pour achever la mission quoi
qu'il advienne et de ne jamais renoncer
quelles que soient les obstacles que la
galaxie dresse sur sa route tu veux bien
arrêter la musique
c'était plus fort que moi tu te moques
de moi au thor où il mais ce n'est pas
méchant tu le sais bien